-It is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
♪♪
-♪ "Hashtags" ♪
♪ "Hashtags" ♪
-We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So, since Mother's Day
is this Sunday,
I sent out
the hashtag #MomQuotes
and I asked you to
share some funny or weird things
that your mom has said.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
We do it every week.
And now and I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
mom quotes from you guys.
This first one's from @shay7296.
She says...
-Nice.
-Nice one.
This next one is from @emoonae.
She says...
Moms do dad jokes.
This next one is from @MaryJoZV.
She says...
Aerohead.
This next is from
@DontLarfAtMeh.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
She says...
-Nice.
♪♪
Oy!
-This next is
from @Mendes Maniac83.
They say...
This next one is from
@elise millsssss.
She said...
High standards.
-Wow.
-This last one here is from
@BlakeKaufman21.
He says...
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to
tonightshow.com/hashtags.